hey this is presh tallwalker
three squares are constructed on the
three sides of an equilateral triangle
each square has a side length equal to
one
a circle is circumscribed about these
three squares
the question is what is the radius of
the circle
i think royce for the suggestion
this problem comes from the 2021 colin
doyle mathematics competition in
australia
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
here's one way to solve the problem
each of the squares has a side that's a
chord of the circle
construct the perpendicular bisector of
each of the chords
this will divide each side of the square
into segments equal to 0.5
next the perpendicular bisector of a
chord of a circle will pass through the
center of the circle
therefore the point where the three
perpendicular bisectors intersect will
be the center of the circle
now let's zoom in on the equilateral
triangle
the equilateral triangle is divided into
six congruent triangles
each of these triangles will be a right
angle triangle
and their angles will be equal to 30
degrees and 60 degrees and the longer
leg of this triangle will be equal to
0.5 and that's opposite the 60 degree
angle
therefore we can calculate the length of
the shorter leg it will be equal to 0.5
divided by the square root of 3.
now let's zoom back out
let's construct the following right
triangle
the shorter leg will be half the side of
the square it'll be equal to 0.5
the longer leg will be 0.5 divided by
the square root of 3 plus 1
and the hypotenuse will be the radius of
the circle
so let's focus on this right triangle
we can then calculate that r is equal to
the square root of the sum of the
squares of the lengths of the legs
so we just need to simplify this formula
we'll expand the square of the binomial
and then simplify and then we'll group
terms and take the square root
so r is equal to the square root of the
quantity 4 divided by 3 plus 1 divided
by the square root of 3 and that's
approximately equal to
1.382
and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time